foreign
76.
good morning Woody and we copy step 76
we will put step 78 and 79 in work from
the ground
regarding Costa sounds great
the voices you hear right now obviously
Woody hoberg using that tablet to step
through the next steps ahead of today's
spacewalk he's speaking on the ground
with Costa mavridis who is the Capcom
once the astronauts switched their suits
to battery power and get outside the
hatch they will hand over
Communications to NASA astronaut and
McLean here in the room
she's known as the ground IV and will be
relaying steps to the astronauts from
here in Mission Control Houston
myvertis will remain on Console to work
with the astronauts that are on board
the station but not outside on the
spacewalk
[Applause]
let me see how far back I can get
myself
during extender
when it's locked yes okay
[Music]
all right
good morning
Carlson grab your coffee
I'm ready back to you if that's 81 and
thanks a lot
[Applause]
yes I've got my weird feather stay close
by a lot okay bye close your
screen reel stay close by the wrong idea
the yellow Hook is
just a minute I'm gonna have some time
check that the depressed pump power is
off off
okay the difference pump is up
and depressed pump enable led
the inability is off
and of course you're hearing some
new voices added to the mix now that it
is of Steve Bowen and Sultan al-niadi
preparing for depress
Ed
beautiful
[Music]
good job
[Laughter]
man ISO valves open you guys can expect
an alert Zone open
foreign
[Laughter]
all right
we are in a Handover of the tracking
data and relay satellite systems that we
use to communicate with the
International Space Station
teams have given a go for
depressurization of the crew lock
portion of the quest airlock where our
two spacewalkers NASA's Steve Bowen and
Sultana nayadi of the United Arab
Emirates are inside and preparing for
their spacewalk
we started with pressure in the airlock
at about
14.7 PSI or pounds per square inch it
continues to drop now at about 11.6
pounds per square inch
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
foreign
depressurization of the crew lock
portion of the quest airlock continues
now looking at about 9.6 pounds per
square inch of pressure
[Laughter]
they'll have a built-in hold shortly
where they wait to check out and make
sure that the readings are accurate
coming from inside the quest airlock and
that temperature fluctuation isn't
causing the pressure to pressure
readings to change
[Laughter]
ah
foreign
pressure in the crew lock continues to
drop as planned now at 8.25 pounds per
square inch
thank you
[Laughter]
ah
a
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
all right
now under 6.5 pounds per square inch of
pressure in the crew lock portion of the
quest airlock
that depressurization continuing to be
monitored by NASA astronaut Woody hoberg
the ground IV in the picture now
as well as team members here in Mission
Control Houston
foreign
one one
okay okay so time on my mark you'll be
taking the depressed pump man ISO valve
to close
ready
Mark if you press conference about
closed expect an alert Zone that has
evolved
okay next up we are going to perform a
leak check you'll use your display
switch to scroll until leak chat
question mark is displayed hold yes two
seconds and follow displayed
instructions
coffee
as expected pressure inside the airlock
now paused at 5 PSI while the crew
conducts leak checks
depressurization will resume shortly
once these leak checks are complete
ensuring everything looks good with the
airlock
ah
yes
the previous
hey check O2 actuators both Eva
thank you
confirmation coming from both astronauts
that their suits have good leak jacks
that's the fun because
[Music]
to open hold on
okay we're standing by I'm still not
quite an Eva hold on
oh
foreign
and Steve you'll take the easy hatch
mpev to open
if you have time to have
open
copy open
depressurization of the crew lock
portion of the quest airlock has resumed
and we are handing over satellite
Communications with the International
Space Station we expect to regain that
Communications very shortly
things continue to move smoothly this
morning as we prepare for our astronauts
to exit the hatch and conduct an
approximately six and a half hour
spacewalk
and Stacia Houston first Steve we heard
you working on the Evie hatchimpev can
you let us know when it's complete
look at that and Woody can you verify
the Emer and PEB is also open
is open step nine complete
okay we copy both thank you guys
voice on the ground currently
communication communicating with the
astronauts is custom of britus they are
in the center of your screen over to the
bottom of the screen is and his left is
Scott Stover today's flight director
the pressure in the crew lock crew lock
portion of the quest airlock is now
under 3 PSI
meanwhile the pressure inside the
spacesuits is about 4.3 PSI
and this view of Sandy Fletcher today's
lead spacewalk officer working through
the tasks and relaying them to teams on
the ground
haha
as depressurization continues in the
crew lock we are now under 2 PSI
the International Space Station flying
266 statute miles over the Indian Ocean
will be coming up over the South Coast
of Australia shortly
yes
one decimal one
okay so time copy that we're just laying
a little behind on the PCS I'll give you
a go for step 10 in just a moment
with coffee standing by
all time I'm guessing we're 30 seconds
to a minute out from that action
coffee
okay so Tom take the depressed pump man
ISO valve to close
I've evolved close
copy that we'll talk on the UAA switch
depressed pump power off
the Chris bomb
is off
all right and with that you guys have a
you guys can record your initial tether
config to and for egress
there's uh my left side on my left side
I
suede feather delivery workstation then
through the d-ring extender gate close
slider locks
slider locked
and the red wheel is unlocked yellow
Hook is gate closed wire locks the green
rail
through my mini workstation on my right
hand side I have
by
lightweight feather eight close by the
lock your cell phones blank hooks
I guess you got Steve my alcohol is
connected to your race cutter
black on black
my green reel is unlocked
and a green hot from the green wheel is
connected to my red wheel
so please get close lock black and black
it's real is unlocked
and from the red wheel I have my red oh
sorry my yellow hook
it's connected to the green wheel and
it's gate closed locked black on black
and the Red Hawk from the red wheel
connected to my right gearing extender
and that hook is get close black on
black
Extender on the right
I have my
face together all hope is
they close black on black
Patchwork is connected to the internal
viewing extender
gay clubs lost black and black
my left side I have a different extender
and they have my
second waist tether and small hockeys
get closed locks black and black
turkey is connected to Miami workstation
that's a good load pass good config
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen and UAE
astronaut Sultan anayati reporting their
configuration of tethers their mini
workstation and other equipment before
they begin opening the hatch
reminder once the DPP gets near zero you
can expect them a hard time
puppies
get great bodies down here a little bit
further
handle some point are important for it
all right
now less than 0.9 PSI in the crew lock
continue to watch it but
that's great
aside from the spacewalk preparations
that we're watching right now on the
International Space Station Andre
fedayev and Dimitri patelan as well as
Frank Rubio are currently in the
exercise portions of their day
astronauts on the International Space
Station need to exercise for about two
hours a day to maintain muscle mass and
proper bone health while in microgravity
that exercise will be limited and
actually restricted while the candid arm
2 is in use today Steve Bowen will be on
the end of the canadarm for part of the
spacewalk that'll be controlled by
NASA's Frank Rubio as well as monitored
by Woody hoberg our ground IV who's in
the center of your screen and who worked
this morning to suit up the two
astronauts now in the crew lock portion
of the airlock
foreign
Houston
an update we are at about 30 minutes of
depressed time looking at our
predictions we are expecting to need the
entire 45 minutes before we take action
so you can expect another 15 minutes of
depress before we take action
if you want coffee maybe two cups
bye
and slightly for almost like we are
we're able to accommodate that 15
minutes
depressurization of the crew law
continues now 0.69 PSI
anticipating about 15 more minutes of
this depressurization
it's a busy time aboard the
International Space Station as always
these days
in addition to this spacewalk there are
two cross Cosmos spacewalks coming up in
may we recently saw the departure of
Northrop grumman's 18th commercial
resupply mission to the International
Space Station on April 21st and just
before that SpaceX is Commerce 27th
commercial resupply Mission departed on
April 15th
we expect to see another SpaceX resupply
Mission the 28th this summer which will
bring up two new International Space
Station rollout solar arrays we refer to
those as irosas part of today's tasks
are preparing the space station for
installation of those irosas on a future
spacewalk
foreign
eat our data
depressurization continues in the crew
lock bringing the airlock itself down to
a vacuum to match that of space
this is about a 45 minute process we
have about 10 minutes left
ah
foreign
okay
keep history
not about 0.5
PSI in the crew lock
again this is down from 14.7 PSI where
we started today and with the rest of
the space station is at as well as
what's very similar to what we
experience here on Earth
all right Stephen Sultan I'm showing
crew lock pressure less than 26
millimeters Steve can you verify the EV
hatch gauge shows less than zero decimal
six if you have skate shows less than
zero decimal six looks like about 0.4
all right with that Steve you have to go
to open and Stow the EV hatch and
reminder once you get it off the seals
you'll want to get the hatch M pev to
closed all right I am opening the
patch and I will get the impact to close
good reports here in Mission Control
Houston as well as from the crew aboard
the International Space Station
the hatch is now open and the crew lock
itself is at a vacuum
again we will start our timer for
today's space walk once the spacesuits
themselves are on battery power
is open
aircraft
[Applause]
is closed practice watch
okay Steve copy that I can verify that
the emergency mpev is closed
gentlemen it's time for me to hand you
over to Ann it was a real honor suiting
you up this morning Sultan you're making
history today congratulations we're so
excited for you hope you both have a
great Eva and we'll see you in just a
few hours fantastic job Woody thank you
very very much thanks for all the help
with the uh thank you
and now that Woody hoberg's job as suit
IV is complete here
fantastic so with that we can start our
post-d press on both dcms you're going
to stagger your switch throws and you
can switch power to battery
if you want power going to batteries
I've got the blank throw bite
good startups
and we can't do the same
okay we copy both power to bat and you
can switch your display to Pro to verify
function display
is functional
is it true
Sultan on the UIA you can switch power
ev1 and 2 to off off and check that all
four LEDs are off
rice coffee and work
P1 power off disease off
V2
power off already is off
okay copy for both of you you can now
disconnect your SCU from your DCM
install the DCM cover and throw your SCU
in the pouch
in the center of your screen is NASA
astronaut and McLean
she's going to be the primary
Communicator with the astronauts while
they are on this today's space walk
okay
he's in the past
still
okay we copy that you both have the DCM
ouse
senator
everybody
circles on the correct side of yours
I got it thanks you're good
foreign
copy both su's are in the pouches at
this time you can check that the
depressed pump man ISO valve is closed
copy for both crew on your dcms you can
take your temperature control valves to
Max hot
valves
copy you may now both switch water to on
o n
um waters on if you want
if your water is on
copy both now in your dcms check blank
bite off
easy one
immediately
you can now set your temperature control
valve as desired and let us know what
that setting is and just a reminder
throughout the Eva today to please
report your changes and try not to do
any changes that are larger than two
if you want copies
okay 82
activity 13 gives five
if you want additional setting is
four when I get there
kev1 initial setting is for
okay we copy five and four thank you can
you please report your suit P gauge
to be easy one 4.3
and 4.3 for images
copy 4.3 and you can set your visors as
required we're about five minutes from a
sunrise
and I agree it is dark outside
okay and with that we can verify that
your suit parameters look good so
that'll take us and we'll take care of
the last step on the Post Street Press
so with that we'll step into the
procedures
so when we're ready Steve your go to
open thermal cover
ing the thermal cover
and Steve remember to release the hook
for the magnetic plate d-ring and attach
the hook to the stowage tether point and
cinch the strap until snug
as we get a live view from outside the
quest airlock we have confirmation that
the spacewalk itself began at 8 11 A.M
central time today as the astronauts
turn their suits to battery power
all right and that's complete
thermal house is open
copy you are now go to egress the
airlock
ah
and Sultan does he aggresses your next
step is going to be to transfer the crew
lock bags out if you want to get eyes on
crew lock bag on two or three
okay I was expecting the idea back
no idea is third
all right coffee
yes you can pass those bags in any order
okay
I love coffee
everybody
good orientation here and get my
and Steve as you get Set uh please also
turn on your hekka
all right let me get myself in a good
configure
I always tell her
first out of the hatch this morning is
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen
he is ev1 you can differentiate between
he and Sultan al-niadi by the red stripe
that is on Bowen's spacesuit
good
and I got a quick move right for hecka
okay hold on I'm ready for a bag okay
I'm turning bag number three for us back
number three
and I know you're tracking but crew lock
bags two and three are going to be
stowed on the airlock Zenith of the
starboard airlock toolbox on 556.
.
the crew members start their day with
Sultana al-nayari passing out some of
the uh
passing out some of the bags that will
be used to Steve Bowen he will then Stow
those on a handrail for you Slater
they're locked her up
cover back
you got it okay here it goes
all right let me put that up on there
on his earring just send us
thank you
as you can see the color is changing
outside of the International Space
Station we will be entering an orbital
Sunrise orbital daylight very soon
the lights on the helmet camera of Steve
Bowen down in the bottom left of your
frame are currently on
the International Space Station sees 16
sunrises and sunsets a day so these
space Walkers will work in alternating
light and darkness throughout their time
today
all right grew up back three it's about
five five six
and we copy Steve crew lock bag 3 on
556.
and Sultan just a reminder the large
small rhetts from these crew lock bags
are going to get stowed on the airlock
d-ring extender
I got coffee and the first bag number
three of it is during extended
copy
okay so proud I'm ready for bag number
two
minutes
outside
that's fine as long as we get it done
all right let's see bag number two
these bags at oneyari are is
transferring to Bowen are stored on the
same handrail
they'll be used later they contain tools
for uh different tasks
recently airlock
and I'm ready for it
here we go
thanks yeah fact number two heading up
here
and that crew lock bag also goes to 556
and that large small red Sultan also
goes to airlock ding-ring extender and
the next item to pass out will be the
GoPro
I'll be honest
number two is attached to 556. 50
the back three is on with a red back she
was going with the Beautiful
okay we copied both crew locks on 556
nicely done and the next thing is to
retrieve and install the GoPro
thanks
ready for your speed
in the handle and I'll take that off
first
safer hand control module okay I think
that the handle is up doesn't
necessarily mean the hand control module
is deployed that takes us to the generic
system of script sheet two decimal one
eight two
positions
ah
GoPro is
and work
on your way all right good with the hook
go thank you
a minute to set that up
another short Handover with the tracking
data and relay satellite systems that
help us communicate with the
International Space Station
the crew members continue to prepare the
crew lock bags that they will use later
on in the spacewalk
I've got the small hook on 550.
we copy a small hook on 550 and Sultan
uh while you wait for him to come back
for the Ida bag we'd like you to check
your safer handles and ensure that they
are both full down
let's copy
hey I got the big hook on
five four specs
and Steve was at 546.
4546.
on the lower
all right we've got it facing the
correct way
head back to your left
okay we copied the handles down
okay copy Sultan and Steve would like
you to do the same thing with your safer
handles and just give them a tap and
make sure they're both full down
stop
and Sultan the next bag will be the Ida
bag and this large small rat will also
go to the airlock d-ring extender
all right
handles down
your left hand is down
and we copy Steve so you can get the Ida
bag from Sultan and throw it on your brt
okay
almost there
a little bit further thank you
yeah
I got this all right so hold on
NASA's Anne McClain our ground IV today
she lived aboard the International Space
Station during Expeditions 58 and 59 and
was a lead spacewalker on two spacewalks
herself
is attached
coming back to you ready yep
okay let me get this back down where I
want
to try to look this thing where I want
them to but it's okay
until Tom the next bag will be crew lock
bag one and you can pass that out to
Steve or you can egress with it your
choice reminder to keep the large small
red on crew lock bag one
yeah Kappy and Steve as you wait for
that um can you check the strap on the
thermal cover the one that you cinched
and to make sure that there are six
lines visible
hold on
foreign
[Music]
thanks for the check
all right
well I'm unfamiliar attack is uh
shows exact
ly right above I so
um give you an idea at some point
appreciate that
if it's well above my head
Kathy will do
all right sometime I'm ready for your
bag
down your way
not quite
a rep you're back
to release the
lock for it hold on
here it comes
I'll see if actually this says what uh
yeah bring it back I'm gonna pass it
back thank you
right here
thank you for the reminder
you're really here right now and now
hold on to it you have a red Donuts I
got a hand on I gotta write on it
and to release the big hook and then it
will be I'll put it on all right
yeah good words on that large small rat
and just another note on this bag Sultan
if you're going to want to use your brt
during translation adaptation then you
can go ahead and Stow tempto crew lock
bag one on that airlock handrail if
you're not going to use your brt then
once you eat grass we'll get it on your
brt
handrail
right now
and then you can grab it on the way out
you can do that yeah okay
all right I have
Mercury walk back by the foot hook on
the airlock handrail
to release my rut
and I will clear the hat for you
thank you sir
and then I'm ready to decrease
Sultan you are go to egress
look at the
thank you
for my feet before
the astronauts have been working through
preparation of their tool bags
as well as ensuring their tethers are in
the proper configuration
now preparing for UAE astronaut Sultan
alniadi to egress the hatch
foreign
[Music]
between my safety teller I
think okay
I'm sure it's right
foreign
once you get out and set your next step
is to receive crew lock bag one uh and
stow it if you want to do that right now
otherwise it can leave it tense node for
translation adaptation
it's right here I can't receive it
at 30 minutes into today's space walk
UAE astronauts Sultan al-nayadi has
egressed the hatch the first ever
spacewalk for an astronaut from the
United Arab Emirates
another good look at both of our space
Walkers here on the right you see NASA's
Steve Bowen with red stripes around the
legs of his spacesuit
that'll help you tell the difference
from him and Sultan al-nayadi who's on
the left side in an unmarked suit
Steve well he is working crew lock bag
one I just want to let you know that we
noticed that the wire tie caddy is not
staying tucked to the Ida bag I just
wanted to put your awareness on it in
case you want to tuck it in somewhere or
add another rep
pulled it out
it's a better place to attack it
[Music]
is
okay copy Sultan you can now turn on
your hekka
that should be better
[Music]
[Applause]
okay we copy your heck is on and just a
quick note to congratulate the UAE for
having their flag on an emu outside the
International Space Station for the
first time
and gentlemen can get it set up for your
buddy checks so much
okay
I see two green lights
I see
up it three latches up one is tape
that's a biology I see you're
uh
right
each other
um
that one goes back with your luck to get
close by the locker there's a small hook
unlocked and the yellow hook
s it blocked a close sidewalk on the
green reel which is unlocked
do my
Right Way feather uh which is gate close
fire to watch
on me so I see up to the kicking thing
never handles check your favorite
handles again
to your left straight your handle down
to your right paper is about
that is right
get checked on full time secures
station
700 is down as well
the right of your other guest clothes
look like a black
is connected by anchor heart boys
I get close black
and black
all right I have to drive
[Music]
black and black
because
I'll check those when I dropped them
okay cool I think you're in a good
country thank you if your hat is dry but
I have to try
all right nicely done my gloves are
normal
Steve your next step is going to be to
translate out to the Anchor hook
location up the cedar spur and out face
one and you're looking for mile marker
57.60
Sultan you're gonna hang out right there
uh once Steve is clear you can tend to
the thermal cover hatch closed as much
as you can obviously won't go all the
way and you can perform translation
adaptation as needed
.
Steve a reminder as you go along phase
one we have those test cables out so
just avoid interburt and contact on the
Zenith and Nader Cedar rails
understand the voices tables
the astronauts have completed their
buddy checks along the way we heard a
handful of
acronyms that will continue to hear
throughout the spacewalk
one of those is the hecka that's the
high def emu camera assembly
as well as the wvs the wireless video
system those will help us get views from
the helmet cameras on the astronauts
additionally we heard the mws that's the
mini workstation that's attached to the
astronauts themselves
as well as the brt the body restraint
tether
used to see the cards
and we copy Steve we see out there just
for your awareness we have all the
external cameras we do not have your uh
helmet cams yet we're working the issue
oh okay
right now Steve Bowen has moved to the
Sita cart that's the crew equipment
translation Aid
meanwhile on screen here is Sultan
anayadi he's working to close the
thermal cover
the main hatch on the quest airlock will
remain open in case the astronauts
needed to Ingress quickly at any time
as this is his first spacewalk he also
has a little bit of extra time to get
used to maneuvering outside in the
vacuum of space
and today we see you getting toward 5760
and you're going to be placing the
anchors just Nader of 5760 the first
hand rail you're going to be looking for
is 3011 and that's the one that is
straight up and down
okay 57.50 I got that mile marker
all right three zero one one
that's what I'm looking for correct
affirmative on 3011 you're going to drop
your anchor hook ev1 anchor hook
ensuring the gate closed and hook locked
up
okay easy one anchor hook
three zero one one
it is closed I'm not gonna Block it's
locked
he's green reel is
unlocked
okay good word Steve you're now going to
go just in board
to the diagonal handrail 3217 and you're
going to put Sultans ev2 anchor on
handrails three two one seven
three two one seven
you want anchor hook
all right all right
stay close by the locks on three two one
seven
feet turning back to the airlock
okay we concur you guys are in a good
safety tether config so with that you
can give Sultana go to release his
weight tether from the airlock b-ring
extender
tell Tom you have to go to release your
waste better from the airlock d-ring
extender
all right copy that reducing my
Westerner from the center
Steve you can continue outboard toward
S6 reminder to give us a gauntlet call
prior to crossing the sarge and your
next step is going to be to drop your
green hook at out on S5 and reminder
that at the sarge you're going to
translate zenith
Sultan uh once you have your waist
together
Sultan once you have your waist tether
uh off you can close the thermal cover
Ed up
okay
thermal cover closed you can now head to
esp2 for bags though
and reminder you're going to translate
you can either translate on the wagon
wheel of the airlock across to esp2 or
you can go direct from the toolboxes
over to esp2 to the starboard side
give me one
all right my goblets are down I am at
the Sarge
okay copy Steve and reminder because it
angles everything's parked in you're
gonna need to go zenith prior to
Crossing and when you cross you're going
to have the non-radier side of the iea
out your left side
all right my left side non-radiator
I see where I am
and Steve as a check once you cross the
struts you're gonna the first Swiss
you're gonna see our whiff two and six
and handrail 2203 and then you know
you're on the right path
216 I'm on the right path and that's a
great cue thank you
sure thing uh you can just head straight
out starboard now
um you're going to be going all the way
along that edge until you get to the S6
handrail 2003 which is going to be the
first one on the S6 long spacer
this one F6 and that's where I dropped
my green hook I think right
good words
this view coming from the helmet camera
of Sultan al-nayari
the International Space Station
currently flying esp2 you're going to be
going to the starboard side just forward
of that trunnion pin uh the good news
out there is that there's no NBL
structure to get in your way so you
should make that corner nice and easy
and you're going to be looking for a
handrail 8007
.007 and I did notice that
I'm feel structurally thanks
all right
stopping to drop my green hook
note the barber pole on the one side
see ya
space station currently flying 258
statute miles over the South Atlantic
Ocean
which we are getting glimpses of in the
background Sultan anayati's camera
to S6 handrail 2009 that'll be with the
iea off to your right side and a
reminder your left hand as you get out
there is going to cross handrail 2008
and that is the one that has wire ties
and mli secured to it that we want to
try to minimize loads into
oh
first there in 2008 in my clothes
[Applause]
on 2003.
it is get close fire lock
that matters on that hook but it is all
right put this your teeth down a little
bit more
yeah good word Steve
um you're right it doesn't need to be
locked but we'll take the belt and
suspenders anytime so you're just
heading outboard to 2009. I agree
outboard
in this video coming from Steve Bowen's
helmet camera
he continues to Stow bags where needed
outside the International Space Station
and his next main task will be to
relocate an articulating portable foot
restraint that will be used later in the
spacewalk
and Steve that's uh you're passing that
bcdu mli right now on 2008 and that's
what we want to try to uh not put loads
in I think you saw it as you went by
I did I float down and make sure I
can cross it
and I'm at 2032 in 2009 now so
I'm at my next work site can't be yes
you are you can Stow the Ida cable bag
right in front of you and yeah there's
gonna be an integral tether to 2010 on
your left and another to 2032 on your
right
I'll get that remote
and then reminder we are going to have
another large small adjustable from the
lid of the bag over to 2032 as well so
there will be two connections on 2032.
in Sultan it looks like you have a good
temp still on the bag when you're ready
you're going to translate back toward
the airlock the way you came to go up
the seat of spur and your next stop is
going to be the port Cedar cart to
retrieve an apfr
first copy 40 cups
foreign
we suggested the outboard and then for
2032 the one that's farthest away from
you but if you see a better way just let
us know
all right
and actually Steve I had that backwards
on 2010 we suggest the inboard but again
whatever you need to get it tacked down
tightly
put it down on the inboard
and Sultan as you get up the seat of
Spurs you're going to be heading up
to the Port City cart
that's copy
and as you get up on phase one Sultan
that Port Cedar card will be off to your
right side and a reminder for you as
well of not touching the test cables
I got it
okay
one of the quarters to 2032 the other
corners of 2010 and the big hook
me
on 2032.
uh back to the top of the back
copy good config Steve
and we will take a glove inspection and
a half check and ensuring your gauntlets
are in place
okay my gutless are employers nothing's
dry I'm checking my clothes
okay copy Steve then you can continue
your tour of station and you can
translate back inboard to the starboard
seater cart to retrieve an apfr and you
will retrieve your green hook on the way
check
and knife work Sultan and we can head to
the uh up the ceter spur when you're
ready
nice work
foreign
this is Mission Control Houston views
from both of our space Walkers now 53
minutes into today's spacewalk to the
starboard Ceda with four which is the
top right and uh note as you translate
that when you get there there is two
apfrs there's one in the top right and
the bottom right we want the one in the
top right that has the Ingress Aid
all right I understand
Bowen and all nighty are heading out to
relocate an apfr that's an articulating
portable foot restraint
it's often used during space walks to
help astronauts secure themselves in one
location as they work on a specific task
we stay together
bringing my friends
we can't get a green hook
and translating under the empty
sultan
[Music]
and Sultan as you get out to the port
Cedar cart you're going to be picking up
the API from the bottom left bottom left
with two and that will also have an
Ingress eight on it
bottom left left two
bankruptcy
10 seconds to a Handover
this is Mission Control Houston we are
in a satellite Handover with the
astronauts aboard the International
Space Station as they continue today's
spacewalk again they are heading out to
relocate an articulating portable foot
restraint
following relocation of the apfr
they will begin moving out to Route
cables
and modify some multi-layer insulation
on one of the modification kits
preparing for installation of future
solar arrays
we're back with you after the Handover
thank you
copy
and Sultan we see you at the apfr when
you have a second we'd like you to
double check that the pitch setting is
papa papa and then we want you to not
change the pitch setting when you
translate
Sultan that was an impressive fix you
have surgeon's hands
thank you
all right I am at the strawberry seed
account
foreign
okay copy Steve and you're looking for
the top right with four
and we are going to have you keep that
apfr in the width and adjust the pitch
knob when you get there
alpharettes before
adjust the piss knob while it's filling
the whiff
yep and I see uh Fox Run on this apfo
and Sultan understand that you see
foxtrot foxtrot
copy Sultan uh stand by one
Steve for yours and uh with four we're
gonna have you uh leaving the apfr in
the with adjust the pitch setting to Fox
Fox and Sultan we were expecting papa
papa on yours so we're talking about it
for a second
it's like we do want the official time
to change it at this location
and Sultan we would like you to have you
adjust that pitch setting uh to papa
papa
so just the pitch setting and you can
leave it in the width if you'd like and
so Steve Fox Fox Sultan papa papa
that should work
we are now one hour into today's
spacewalk
the astronauts have made their way out
to the Ceta cart the crew equipment and
translation Aid and they are both
working on a separate apfr articulating
portable foot restraint
verifying the settings are needed to be
used later today
foreign
box
all right I have the atfr and fox fox
and the pitch knob is locked and able to
be depressed
that's a great word Steve as you know so
you can retrieve that apfr now with the
Ingress Aid and stow it on your brt
all right that's going to be at work in
a minute
we could have uh papa papa and this will
be a phone and pick up is locked and
could be
okay good word Sultan
um you are now going to pick up that
apfr with the Ingress Aid and throw it
on your brt
s
as you both work those apfrs onto your
brt big picture uh you're going to be
pretty synced up now you're going to be
heading out to S6 uh just know we're
about five minutes to a sudden so a
sunset if you want to
set your visors accordingly
thank you very much
again
the crew members continue with the first
task of the day which is fixing the
appropriate settings on these
articulating portable foot restraints
they will Stow those on their body
retractable tether
the apfr will be used later in the
spacewalk
[Music]
copy
and just to confirm man I was
translating on the
hands of the God and release the brakes
yes good words and we'll also catch them
at the end of the Eva Steve's actually
back on this see to cart to pick up the
other apfr and a little later but that's
always a good check and we'll always
take it
that's empty
hey have a rough the apfr apfr has been
my
goes by
it's all done are you good
assume I'm good to translate ahead of
you see right
I think that's the plan yep yes we were
just talking about that you are going to
uh translate ahead of him so you're
going to continue outboard prior to
Crossing you're going to cross where the
anchor hooks are and then a little bit
outboard of that prior to crossing the
surge we'll make sure your gauntlets are
in place and you're going to be
translating Zenith from there
and so you're going to go kind of up
face one and then across the side
all right keep an eye on myself over
there as you go by it there or something
now that both crew members have the apfr
the articulating portable foot restraint
with them they're heading out to the S6
truss where they will install those
apfrs and prepare for the next task of
routing some cables to prepare for
future installation of new International
Space Station roll out solar arrays also
known as irosas these will be delivered
later this year
all right
foreign
[Music]
and for both of you the same translation
path as Steve took out the first time so
as you cross the sarge you're going to
come Zenith and then cross onto uh
S4
and you should have the non-raider side
out your left side and the iea out your
right side
coffee thank you
as you can see
Israel that
from the top
yeah Sultan so before before uh crossing
the sarge we'll have you ensure your
gauntlets are in place
and then you're going to translate
zenith
and then when you go across the struts
and you get to S4 have that non-radiator
side out your left side the first thing
you should see is with two and width 6
and then handrail 2203
all right you're ahead of these Sultan
you're on the right path when you cross
over
uh what did they cross over the other
side Ed
and I take care I'm I expect my
gauntlets right down I took the
expected route and I'm by
the handrail to one zero three hidden
outboards
okay we copied 2103 and heading outboard
as you can see the program when you get
out there
zero three yeah so two so you're going
to hook to your green hook to 2004 which
is one handrail outboard of 2003
and then two handrails outboard of that
is where you're gonna actually cross on
the inboard side of the bcdu that's open
so the first thing you want to do though
is get your green hook on 2004.
nice coffee
this view from the helmet camera of
Sultan anayati United Arab Emirates
astronaut
on the first spacewalk for an emirati
lighting looks a little different
outside the International Space Station
right now as the station itself is in an
orbital night time
again we'll see several changes in uh
we'll see several sunrises and sunsets
today during the spacewalk
as it currently flies 265 statute miles
over the Indian Ocean
okay green clock for 82
before
okay good work Sultan and well your
pause here just a reminder actually for
both of you for the helmet lights
um if you push the button multiple times
you might get one light two light and
then they'll go off so if the light
seems dim you may not have both lights
on
and Sultan you're going to continue out
along S6 when you see with nine you're
going to take a right
and you're going to see handrail 2024
and that's going to be just on the
inboard side of the bcdu so you're just
going to head straight across
look at that
and Steve you're just heading out to
where you were before to drop your green
hook on 2003 and then head straight all
the way outboard
and I'm working on that now
it is
and that short hand rail there Sultan is
2025 and then it'll be a kind of a reach
around to the other side and then you
can go outboard
and you're going to be looking for your
S6 with 15.
and Sultan one more body orientation
reminder when you get out to S6 and you
find with 15 we'd like you to position
your body over the iea and ensure that
your safety tether is on the iea side of
that whiff and there's two widths there
with 15 is the one that kind of points
in the direction of the radiator
let's copy
I see what you've been
foreign
because that apfr was in a different
configuration than we expected when you
picked it up we're going to have you
verify the settings and so when you're
ready for the settings let me know
um
you are going to be installing at a
clocking of 12.
all right it's on 2003
I uh Heather gets thrown in my apfr
interesting
all right good word Steve I understand
you got your green hooked Down You're
Gonna head all the way outboard so you
can't go anymore and take a right after
the iea and you're heading around to S6
with 31
on my way
and I see papa papa
and on the
all I see call apparently and
the settings
okay your full settings are going to be
12 papa papa Fox 8 12 papa papa Fox
eight
all right 12 papa papa Fox eight it work
oh
all right
in a brief loss of signal with the
International Community
with the International Space Station as
our space Walkers continue today's
spacewalk now one hour and 18 minutes
since they switched their suits to
battery power
back with you after a Handover Sophie
called it I missed it we've got Sultan
working 12 Papa pop at Fox 8 and with
15. and Steve you're heading to with 31.
I am heading to roof 31.
31 is here
okay and I have good installation
it falls to this test
check on the
shop
and Sultan we got a copy the good pull
twist test and just looking for black on
black
it's black and black sorry yes so good
luck I'm black we have it clicking on it
okay
good check thank you and can you confirm
12 papa papa Fox eight
papa papa
copy a good work you can hang out and
take a couple pictures while Steve gets
his apfr installed Steve you've got
settings of six fox fox 2.
Fox 2.
okay
and Sultan as you are taking pictures I
will also take a glove inspection half
check and just double checking your
gauntlets are in place please
where do that
foreign
we'll be heading to the cable routing
and the mod kit and just a reminder you
do have cup Pages if you want to read
about it first
let's copy that
as the astronauts installed their
articulating portable foot restraints
they will then begin moving on to the
next task one of the major tasks today
which is routing cables in preparation
for future installation of International
Space Station rollout solar arrays
there
in this view from Celtics
in this view from Sultan anayari's
helmet camera
on the left on his left glove you can
see a small what looks like a notebook
that includes some reference information
affirmative Fox 2
Fox
[Applause]
go to two
copy Steve and we get a full twist and
black on black
pool black or black
issue
copy and verify the pitch knob is locked
and can be depressed
all right hello look it's on the other
side
foreign
Steve that completes the installation
and so we'll take a glove inspection hap
check-in gauntlets please
look good
Love Steve so we can now for both of you
move over to the 1B cable routing uh
Steve you're going to go directly to the
left side
of the mod kit Sultan as you go outboard
past TV's apfr you're going to do a fair
lead on the short handrail on the
radiator side of the iea it's handrail
2061 and again it's it'll be off to your
right side on the radiator side
side
let's copy that says
for both of you as you go out there a
couple reminders about the mod kit we
don't want to translate simultaneously
on the mod kit we want to keep
translation rates lower than three
seconds per foot and then avoid cyclic
loading into the mod kit
oh
and for both of you for your awareness
you got a happy team down here you are
slightly ahead of timeline
that's good to know thank you great
thanks
I'm trying to track my
covers
it seem to have lost sight of them
um
I don't see a rank Rock obviously but it
I think that's way
I think it's behind me oh sorry uh you
mean
uh it is
okay
to help me do a quick if you can yeah
just keep your feet slow it's low and
people dating uh counterclockwise what
are you doing
and see it towards the iea please
Russia
yes that continue continue your feet
down bring your feet down
no and unwind unwind just for 20 degrees
and try to lift them a little bit at
your feet
okay now bring them down
and then
clockwise station
yes